ich mache jetzt jetzt bin ich gespannt
ob der effekt klappt
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein experiment denn
ich habe was entdeckt of interest und
auf instagram kursieren gerade videos
und ich weiß nicht warum aber in meinem
buch fehlt in diesem feature kommt
ordnung kuchenrezepte vielleicht weil es
mein hobby ist und ist mein interesse
weckt und da habe ich jetzt was gesehen
eine torte die nennt sich bolo tsunami
die kommt anscheinend aus portugal und
ich habe dann googelt was heißt symbole
tsunami ist heißt zunahme kuchen
ja und ich verstehe es nicht okay denn
es ist nett horte die wird praktisch
richtig schön geschichtet und wird auch
so verschenkt und dann nimmst du diese
folie ab und diese schokoladenmasse die
dort da oben also schicht war die fließt
über die torte und es gibt halt videos
diesen recht gut und videos die sind
halt so voller fehler und es gibt noch
kein so richtiges rezept davon und ich
habe mir gedacht warum machen wir das
nicht einfach zum kick trend 2020 wir
probieren es heute wir machen heute
einen tsunami kuchen und jetzt macht
auch sinn denn der schokoladen tsunami
gefliest praktisch über diese ganze
torte und überdeckt alles weil ein
tsunami immer alles okay ich habe es
verstanden
ich fand es zuerst mal an ich rede mir
ja immer so viel dialekt ich fange jetzt
zuerst einmal an und werde einen biscuit
so bereiten einen schokoladen biscuit
zeichen basis rezept ich mache den
kuchen 20 cm groß gar nicht so groß
sonst braucht er ja noch mehr
schokoladenmasse und dann probieren sie
es einfach ob es klappt oder nicht ob
das experiment gelingt oder eben nicht
für den biss wird nämlich drei eier
diesen bereits zimmer waren 75 gramm
zucker und eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt 60 gramm mehl und 25 gramm cacau
also wichtig beim bis wird ist einfach
eier zucker master richtig schaumig
rühren beziehungsweise cremig sogar
nicht nur schauen
das heißt die eier kommen jetzt hier
rein da kommen jetzt salz zucker und
vanille dazu und wie gesagt dann wird
das ganze für etwa 10 bis 15 minuten
sogar richtig cremig verrührt so könnt
ihr auch das backpulver weglassen und
der biscuit wird einfach schön locker
weil eben die eier maßen schön locker
gerührt wurde jetzt kann ich hier das
mehl mit dem kakao noch 7
solltet ihr auf jeden fall machen damit
einfach keine klümpchen gibt das mehl
ist zwar recht klümpchen frei aber cacau
klumpp doch ganz gerne mal ganz
vorsichtig unterheben und dann den
schneebesen auch nicht an den rand
klopfen denn dann klopft ihr die
eingeschlagene luft wieder aus das
wollen wir nicht
jetzt habe ich hier meinen wagen bereits
auf 20 cm eingestellt ich stell dir
einzahlen rand denn ich habe noch eine
zweite biscuit masse angerührt
ich dachte mir sicher ist sicher ich
mach mal 2 bei den experimenten geht es
zwar nicht immer darum das ist super gut
gelingt aber ich bin ja das ist gelenkt
und nicht ändert wir beim asian food
geld da einfach so gar nichts wurde
da muss ich übrigens den muss ich noch
mal testen den muss ich das ja das kann
ich so nicht belassen
und ich glaube bei dem kuchen hier ist
einfach die schwierigkeit dieser klausur
so hinzukriegen dass es einmal
schönfließ nicht so fest ist aber es
muss ja dann auch die richtige menge
sein also dass der kuchen dafür nicht
ertrinken aber davon wird zu wenig sein
ist schon so schwierig ok also ich hab
hier nochmal die gleiche masse füllen
die noch kurz hier ein und dann streiche
ich beide schön glatt und dann wird es
gleich schon gebacken
[Musik]
der biss wird ist jetzt gebacken richtig
perfekt den dass ich kurz abkühlen aber
kann schon mal die füllung machen
da dachte ich wäre es doch ganz cool der
boden ist ein schoko boden da möchte ich
noch werden rein schichten und dann
hätte ich gerne helle creme und später
diesem tsunami die zunahme mit lasur
dann auch wieder als schokolade also
mache ich jetzt der deutsche futter
creme dafür nehme ich 500 gramm milch
eine prise salz und 90 gramm zucker
etwas man in der extrakt 45 gramm stärke
drei eigene und drei 120,4 butter ich
denke so rein von meinem gefühl her
dürfte die menge zu viel sein also
wahrscheinlich ist davon die hälfte ganz
gut aber ich mache jetzt lieber etwas
mehr und hab was übrig also deutsche
buttercreme wie gesagt die butter
sondern weich sein
und jetzt nimmt er im prinzip einfach
nur einen topf gibt die stärkere die
eigelbe und das eiweiß einfach
aufbewahren einfrieren zum beispiel oder
auch etwas anderes rost sauber nein weiß
brauchen wir heute nicht dann vanille
extrakt dazu damit ein vanillepudding
wird zucker und salz und jetzt mit der
milch aufgießen und schönen tütchen frei
verrühren und dann die masse als pudding
aufbauen lassen hier auf dem herd bei
mittel hoher hitze dabei ständig rühren
damit nichts anbrennt
jetzt wird der pudding fest er darf
jetzt auch einmal aufkochen und dann die
sich ihnen direkt in einen flachen
teller also mit bisschen rand damit
einfach schneller abkühlt decke ihn an
der oberfläche mit frischhaltefolie ab
damit sich keine haut bindet und lasse
ihn komplett ab und in der zeit können
wir schon mal die zunahme noch so machen
da überlege ich mir jetzt mal was ja da
war es nämlich so da habe ich gefunden
dass es oft mit kondensmilch gemacht
wird ich mache mit schokolade und mit
saurer sahne anscheinend viele nehmen
dann noch milchpulver das habe ich nicht
aber ich denke mal kurz aus und dann
zeige ich euch die zu haben
[Musik]
also für den burloh tsunami nämlich 200
konzerne 200 gramm zar peter kurth
höhere 250 gramm gezuckerte kondensmilch
200 gramm saure sahne 250 kg milch und
15 gramm speisestärke ja anscheinend ist
die gezuckerte kondensmilch ein
wichtiger bestandteil ich denke die gibt
diesem dieser klausur den glanz wie
gesagt dieses milchpulver habe ich nicht
und ich habe es so viele verschiedene
rezepte gefunden und bei den meisten hat
einfach nicht geklappt also dachte ich
mir mach halt dein eigenes ja ich würde
zwei vorgehen ich will jetzt erstmal
eine garage herstellen also sahne in den
topf und aufkochen lassen ich habe mich
in der sekunde in der j die kameras
umgestaltet um entschieden wir machen
keine ganache zuerst denn sonst bräuchte
ich will aber nur einen topf benutzen
ich gebe jetzt die sahne in den topf
trotzdem gibt die schokolade nicht so
schnell geht so schnell ich habe mich
mit ihr unterhalten und dann
währenddessen noch mein rezept im kopf
um geplant
denn die stärke muss auch eingekocht
werden also sahne und milch stärkeren
kurz berühren
ich weiß auch noch irgendwie das ganze
jetzt aufkochen lassen wenn man das
ganze hell machen will muss man
natürlich die menge war der selbst mehr
praktisch die dunkle schokolade weg oder
die kuvertüre weg nimmt dann weiße
kuvertüre da verändert sich den namen
also das müsste ich dann noch mal
ausprobieren
ich bin aber nicht so weit ist es also
das lassen wir jetzt kochen damit die
stärke die meist stärke einfach bindet
praktisch ähnlich wie beim pudding
gerade eben
ich hab mich nur was die saure sagen
darin so die verständnis
vielleicht um einfach den geschmack so
ein bisschen von dem süßen wegzunehmen
dass es einfach so eine leichte säure
nathan hat das kocht jetzt da gebe ich
die gezuckerte kondensmilch dazu so dann
schalte ich jetzt im herd aus denn die
gefahr dass die kondensmilch jetzt am
topfboden fest brennt ist so hoch ok
jetzt dekorateure rhein in kleinen
stückchen ihr könnt sie auch fein hacken
vorher oder reiben dann geht es noch
schneller aber normalerweise müsste die
rest weil man es eigentlich schon
ausreichen
jetzt einfach rühren
zu hören sind
da bin ich ja ich bin doch ich kann doch
wahrlich verstanden du kannst kein
wahrlich kann wahrlich kann löffel
sprache türkisch englisch und deutsch
die schokolade hat sich gelöst und jetzt
kommt hier noch die saure sahne torte
ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal sie dient
dem geschmack und ich hoffe sie für
sagte mir jetzt nicht die komplette
creme
es sieht nicht schlecht aus sollen wir
den geschmackstest machen
jetzt zwei große löffel schmeckt gut
aber gut ich glaub später mit den
erdbeeren und wo wird das gut kommen
ich möchte jetzt einfach
sicherheitshalber die masse noch sieben
damit ich einfach keine klümpchen habe
also wenn dieser zunahme cache nicht
klappt dann manchmal einfach nur dafür
besser raus dann erstmal allem im löffel
daraus trinken die erdbeeren ein und
fertig wie klanglos untergegangen
könntest du auch nur den versuch statt
lukas tsunami war das ist natürlich das
richtig gut magazin das lasse ich jetzt
komplett abstellen denn ich muss ja
wissen wie die konsistenz ist
ich finds ja fast schon zu dick wie die
konsistenz ist wenn die masse abkühlt
dann muss ja auch fließen aber halt
nicht zu dünn werden
wir werden sehen kann sein dass ich
vielleicht noch mal sahne oder manager
so fügt aber jetzt warten wir einfach ab
richtig ab und wir können jetzt
eigentlich schon weil der bestwert
abgekühlt ist und die der vanille
pudding auch können schon die torte
füllen und das kommt jetzt noch für
schaltfaule drucker einfach das schwabe
trick und legen das jetzt hier so drauf
hat man das gesehen
die weiche butter kommt jetzt in die
schüssel und wird schaumig gerührt also
es geht jetzt einfach mit der
buttercreme weiter die rührt ihr
wirklich richtig weiß cremig jetzt sieht
es ja noch relativ gelb aufarbeiten wird
so weiß cremig aber die maschine scheint
sich gleich an den pudding könnte jetzt
entweder so lassen und einfach nur kurz
verrühren
oder ihr streicht ihnen durch ein sieb
damit einfach auch hier die klümpchen
verschwinden und so mache ich das jetzt
kurz und einfach hier das fleißige
lieschen ihr könnt aber auch ein ganz
normales hause nehmen so wie ich vorhin
nur habe ich hier den vorteil dass sie
einfach nicht im teig sauber haben muss
oder mit schneebesen sondern das einfach
schön durch strömten
[Musik]
jetzt gibt dir den pudding einfach
esslöffel weise zur buttercreme dazu und
schlagt alles schön cremig
[Musik]
ich mach nicht denn die zeit
ok also zuerst kurz hier den biss wieder
auslösen
ich habe den bist nicht einfach komplett
abkühlen lassen und dann noch mal ganz
kurz mit dem blech in den kühlschrank
gestellt
so lässt das sich gleich besser
schneiden
die tortenböden schneide ich jetzt macht
durch das geht mit orten sehe ich ganz
gut und vor allem auch gleichmäßig dann
trägt jetzt noch einmal um und kann die
back folie lösen
und jetzt geht schon ans schichten der
torte ich habe einfach ein torten retter
des ressorts und jetzt kommt hier
drumherum eine folie denn die torte wird
dann mit der folie mit der toten folie
sozusagen verschenkt und angerichtet
dann hat man diese schönen geschichten
die man sieht und dann nimmt man die
folie weg und hat eben diesen tollen
effekt okay sie eine extra hohe der eine
sonne hat heute werden
und die darf jetzt halt auch nicht so
dumm sein
ich habe jetzt einfach so eine extra
folie bestellt das mache ich glaube ich
vielleicht sogar doppelt nirgendwo hin
ich habe von der preis gleich ja so
sieht gut aus
es wird sogar ohne halten
ich glaube ja wobei ich mach später eine
schleife drum ich glaube ich nehme ich
nehme keine denn doch nicht
doch es ist ein experiment ich kann mich
noch rom entscheiden
und das kann ich ja später noch
wegnehmen für die optik aber mir ist es
glaube ich jetzt gerade echt zu heikel
und weil ich stabilität brauche setzt
sich jetzt noch den ring außen rum
den nehme ich dann natürlich weg bevor
wir den effekt machen aber die creme ist
jetzt noch seitdem also auch jetzt
gerade diese buttercreme und die wir da
im kühlschrank fest und stand denke ich
kriegen wir das gut hin
ich habe jetzt hier noch erdbeeren die
geschichte ich jetzt noch rein und zwar
entferne ich das grün
ich nehme jetzt leider auch ein bisschen
was von der erdbeere weg aber das könnte
er einfach naschen den part hirsch wir
machen einfach gleich smoothies und dann
nehme ich die erdbeere und halbierten
und setzte jetzt mit der schnittkante
nach außen an die folie damit man sie
später von außen auch gut sieht
[Musik]
jetzt einfach die mitte mit den
restlichen erdbeeren auslegen und die
brauchte jetzt nicht verlieren sondern
können sie wirklich schön im ganzen
reinlegen
jetzt habe ich hier die vanille creme
und die fülle ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel ist so ist das füllen etwas
einfacher und wir müssen natürlich
darauf achten dass ihr die torte sauber
gefüllt denn man weder von außen die
einzelnen schichten sehen
daher ist der spritzbeutel super
geeignet damit eine schöne gerade fläche
habt dann ist erstmal inneren also die
ganzen erdball lüftungen erstmal
bedecken und dann die creme schön gerade
abschließen lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommt der zweite trockenboden drauf
er achtet darauf dass keine brösel an
der folie sind
dann wieder eine schicht creme
die war das vorhin die creme wird auf
jeden fall für zwei torten ausreichen
es reicht doch noch für eine das wird
auch ein kalorien tsunami aber als ich
heute morgen in unserer besprechung
gesagt hab ich mache hier tsunami cache
vielleicht auch zwei haben sich alle
gefreut
der mache hat faktor wie schade dann
wissen wir dass er alles aufessen und
ich war so ja wieder macht alle in
waghäusel und oberhausen herum dick
[Musik]
und dann werde ich die torte jetzt erst
mal kühl stellen damit die buttercreme
festwirt und wir kontrollieren gleich
mal die zunahme massa ist es anhört die
zunahmen lassen denn die muss ja im
gekühlten zustand soccer also im
kühlschrank halten zustand muss die ja
dieser konsistenz haben sich wenn das
konnte sie ihren kühlschrank ist ein
buttercreme habe ich übrig aber ach
kommt ja noch drauf hat ist hier und
jetzt auch noch das irgendwie aufzuheben
die 40 gramm butter nebenbei auch noch
[Musik]
schwester noch nicht so ganz ob das
gleich klappt beim ersten mal
deswegen fühle ich jetzt noch eine torte
sicher ist sicher heute darf nichts
schiefgehen
ich setze jetzt auch gleich den ringen
wieder aus warum habe ich wollte
erdbeeren jetzt mal so reinsetzen sieht
man es auch schön von außen
[Musik]
okay ich bin gespannt
für mein empfinden ist das zu dick für
mein empfinden ist es genau so dick wie
bei den anderen
das eben auch druck gemacht haben
zitiert das fließt gar nicht so schwer
macht eine abstimmung gießen war seine
rein oder mädels
okay okay was sagen weil contento will
ich jetzt nicht noch mehr ist das wäre
mir dann schon so süß mit sahne weil man
kann sich ja sonst nix ich wohl kurz an
dann schon sein okay ich hoffe das
klappt jetzt einfach so weil ich bis
jetzt hat nicht mehr erwärmen ich meine
jetzt gerade so schön abgekühlt und ich
habe jetzt den letzten schritt so zu
sagen ich habe ca 200 mal gucken wie
viel ich nehme wir machen mal langsam
die presse aus
wie könnte ich das testen könnte
ich weiß ja stets volles experiment es
blöd wenn ich jetzt das praktisch ich
muss was haben wo ich dann den ring so
wegziehen kann und dann fließt es
darunter so drüber
keine ahnung ob das jetzt gemacht was
ich mache aber ich will zumindest mal
sehen ob es fließt
weiters war ja darin will ich sehen wie
es fließt schon kommen dass das ding
einfach runter fällt eine hand hätte
halten sollen gleichgewichtsübungen aber
ich glaube jetzt passt wirklich
und jetzt kommt der magische moment und
es wäre dieses jetzt ich habe noch die
frage mit der höhe und der menge weil du
darfst nicht zu wenig haben damit es
wirklich am kompletten kuchen runter
fließt oder bauen hat zu viel haben weil
sonst er trinkt sie auch gibt's da nicht
bestimmt eine formel der kamera bestimmt
eine formel auf standorte sowie unser
büro also für ein drittel
okay wir machen das so ok also ich finde
das war optimistisch und ich finde die
konsistenz guckt mal so vom löffel
runter es fließt nicht vom löffel soll
aber auch nicht denn wenn sich das löst
fließt drüber klappt
toi toi toi
ich bin sehr optimistisch so 8 cm hoch
ich fühle es jetzt nach augenmaß
vielleicht kann ich auch schon der ring
abnehmen dann sehe ich es weil jetzt ist
die torte fest
es sieht schon ein sie hätte für meinen
geschmack bisschen höher sein dürfen ja
jetzt schon noch der eine boden
aber nehmen wir so müsste ich jetzt noch
mal packen die handbewegung hätte dir zu
lesen
ok
ich mache jetzt ungefähr ein drittel
ich meine wenn hier jetzt heute alles
mit diesem augenmaß wieder passt dann
möchte ich mich bitte als offizielle
augenmaß expertin eintragen lassen
wenn ich nehme jetzt auch noch das das
war ja alles sauber grundsätzlich war
coleman gebildet das haus wie charlie
chaplins gut von der form her
doch gott ich habe auch die befürchtung
drittel
[Musik]
das heißt für mich ich muss jetzt noch
mal ich denke schon dass müssten drittel
auf jeden fall das reicht niemand
ok ich hoffe das wirkt sich jetzt nicht
auf die torte also auf das aus aber es
war kühl schrank alt ich werde gleich
ich mache jetzt noch mal die menge und
dann sehen wir gleich
ich mache jetzt einfach die doppelte
menge nochmal denn ich habe noch die
andere worte die sicherheit drei stunden
später hat sie noch einmal die masse
gemacht und die geheime geheimformel
sagt wir machen und drittel wann ist es
um drittel
ich hoffe das verbindet sich jetzt halt
weil noch ein bisserl joshua schaufel
drauf schaufelt auf
also man sieht halt die andere die
untere hat sich schon bissl nochmal
gefestigt im kühlschrank man sieht einen
leichten farbverlauf aber es war doch
nicht schlimm
mainz reicht ich denke schon
aber jetzt wenn jetzt so überlegt so ja
und in vielen videos war es dann noch so
dass dann obendrauf noch schokostreusel
bei manchen gut aus bei manchen nicht
aber ich mache jetzt und dann machen
jetzt gleich eine schleife drum damit
ich die unschönen klebestreifen
wegnehmen kann ich jetzt auch noch mal
eine kunst für sich
gott hat es auch schon fallen sehen
[Musik]
im linklink okay wir lassen uns jetzt
noch mal so und dann gucken wir gleich
ob es klappt und hier muss jetzt echt
sagen zahlt sich der torten ständer also
der text orten ständer torten serviert
platte mit fuß zahlt sich echt aus denn
dieser rand wird verhindern dass die
schokolade dann über läuft so die
theorie
das werden wir sehen
ich mache noch einen abschluss
erinnerungsfoto
ich hab doch gesagt ich hab' 'ne box mit
geschenkbänder welche farbe das war sehr
lieb ich das hier gut dass banden immer
man hat mir immer nur so ein so schönes
dann der trick das so nach außen wegen
geschmeidiger voll vielmehr geht es gar
nicht dass schwabing mir sagt mach es
nochmal auf der anlage schwarzer partner
sagt das ist auch die zeit der schweiz
vor
ich höre jetzt auf dem bad machen ok ich
versuche das jetzt weg zu nehmen ohne
dass es auf geld schon mal hörte nummer
eins nach das hinterland sich daran dass
sie keine polo tsunami jetzt bin ich
gespannt ob der effekt klappt wenn ich
diese folie hochheben und wegnehmen muss
die schokoladensauce komplett über die
torte fließen und dabei noch schön
aussehen und schmecken
[Musik]
jetzt ist es soweit ich schaue jetzt auf
der bono tsunami cache funktioniert
die entstehen
[Musik]
was wir bei dem ein drittel nicht
berechnet habe was auf der folie über
bleibt kaum lauf weiter kaum noch weiter
und bräuchte ich nachher wie sieht's bei
euch mal aus ja ich glaube der läuft
jetzt noch so ein bisschen so zeigt kaum
der läuft noch runter doch der läuft
noch ich sehe also eigene aber ich muss
sagen also für dafür dass es alles so
nach augenmaß war und alles so in meinem
kopf berechnet und zum ersten mal unser
direkt vor der kamera getestet muss ich
schon sagen dass dieses experiment
geglückt ist
jetzt muss nur noch schmecken aber da
mache ich mir keine sorgen aber ich
würde sagen wo tsunami kate jetzt sieht
es zwar aus wie ein unfall aber der
effekt war kohl ich glaube es kommt auf
den effekt an ich werde dann gleich vom
dicken mehr dazu machen für den zweiten
den ich auch vertrete und dann läuft es
auf einmal zurück
aber ich glaube so geschmacklich müsste
schon bombe bombe sein
nach der partie hätte eigentlich den
kuchen probieren sollen jetzt hat er ihn
auf konzerne telefoniere revolution muss
ich halte es eine partie
schokolade fenster klopft man also jetzt
auch so ein unfall ist ein effekt
gesehen ja hallo hier zwei kommt kommen
die probieren
alle zusammen haben die riesen augen
das muss ich leider kurz kollegen kampf
pro widmer alle partie auch er ist mit
der creme problem die schokocreme ich
finde es schon hammer lecker muss man
mal testen
[Musik]
geschmacklich ist echt perfekt
vor allem weil die schokocreme noch so
weich ist
also wenn mir jemand so die torte
präsentieren wir euch denken was war das
für ein unfall aber vorher somit der
schicht schon schon ziemlich cool album
experiment geglückt
und wie gesagt die folie braucht er hat
auf jeden fall eben für den effekt klar
wird auch gehen wir mal einfach nur ein
tortenring nimmt aber ich finde dann
geht einfach der effekt verloren denn im
prinzip einfach nur noch das schoko
suppe darüber und vorher sieht man dass
es eben eine perfekte geschichte torte
das mit einem flüssigen
schokoladenüberzug ihrem experiment
geglückt also probiert gerne mal aus
falls ihr weitere ideen habt für diese
videoreihe dann schreibt sie in die
kommentare
und ich hoffe euch gefällt das video ihr
könnt ihr mal schreiben findet er dieser
bolo tsunami cache ist könnte der cache
trend 2020 werden ja oder nein
findet ihr es cool oder sagt ihr so
danach seht einfach furchtbar aus also
ich finde geschmacklich finde ich hammer
also für mich mega trend megatrend j
trend samira trend okay samira kleines
am ihrer sagt auch yahoo könnte auch
sagen was sagst du ins off ist anja fliß
wir sind ok also er sagt wenn ihr einen
perfekten namen habt für diesen kuchen
dann schreibt sie in die kommentare oh
man die youtuber kind also bis zum
nächsten mal
wir kommen von außen also würde ich
auffangen und die folie die mister auch
aus garbsen die komplette schokolade ist
das ist der trend 2020 also wirklich ein
absoluter hammer ding das ding wird in
die annalen eingehen und zwar nicht ins
war ein sturm - also ein ganz großes
ding
so hat noch nie gesehen es ist wirklich
ist es absolut rennt ich glaube das wird
jetzt morgen überall in den zeitungen
stehen und überall in allen tv und
quizshows nachgemacht ok wie geht es
jetzt schatz machen wir was soll ich das
ding ins hochheben
wie heißt es tsunami motto tsunami heißt
es und zwar bolognese und tsunami
gleichzeitig das wird ein stummer extrem
freuen und essen was ist auch das
besondere an diesen kuchen ist ihr kennt
doch diesen spuk schutz was du hast das
ist auch ein spruch schulz und zwar es
ist sozusagen einige monate genau das
ist ihre plexiglas heutzutage jeder oder
so vom gesicht und hier ist alles okay
jetzt ist nicht einfach hochheben
ok meine frau macht es jetzt wirklich
ihr seht es morgen in jeder zeitschrift
in jedem in jeder fernsehsender bloß
damit es diesmal ein bisschen mehr als
ein drittel drin einfach dass es
wirklich auf einem schlag was ich noch
machen will ist das war ein echt
vergessen gut dass wir noch ein ende
machen und gut dass ich noch eine torte
habe denn ich nominiere jemanden ich
nominiere gleich drei personen um diese
produktion mit orte den kick drum 2020
nachzumachen platzen oder 1 sturm
staffel platz zwei und platz nummer drei
kelly mit lok genau genau 43 ihr müsst
diese promis machen die heißt wohl
gleichzeitig zusammen nacheinander genau
machen wir das eigentlich alle drei
macht und dann die tage so hinstellt und
dann beim bewegen es funktioniert also
als ich das mal wann er uns kelly studie
auch aber ständig neuen einblicken
hundekuchen gemacht also polo tsunami
ich mache was ich will ich jetzt nicht
ihr ding machen ich habe ich nicht
kränken
aber ich mache gerade eine handy
aufnahme und von da und ich finde ich
die haarigen nichts was soll s das ist
ein schutz und gucken ja
ok ich hoffe diesmal jetzt noch schöner
als vorher ok jetzt wichtig mein polo
tsunami sturm kelly maranello ist jetzt
bin ich gespannt wie ihr das hinsehen
ist hier oben und dann praktisch
diesmal war es etwas das war ein
richtiger tsunami weil ich kann ich mich
darunter legen ok herzlich willkommen
das ist ein polo tsunami das ist einfach
die richtige menge heraus zu finden ist
etwas für ich habe ich vorhin war es
shop.com ich schneide dir jetzt an dann
musst du jetzt anderswo wieder kommt
kommt das machen wir jetzt auch die zeit
ich kümmere mich nur beim zweiten
schwung die milch weil ich sie nicht
mehr kupfer drauf gemacht haben
angebrannt deswegen schmeckt so auch ich
ja schon leichte schokoladig was ich da
drin
schokolade gott im himmel ohne trampolin
ja so eine art flüssiger pudding mit
[Musik]
schwarzer hätte ich weiß warum er das
hat man das besteck nicht findet weil es
um geräumt haben gern hammer wahnsinn so
kelly
mal war
und sturm jetzt findet euch mal
schönbett trank 2020 schmeckt gut und
ich bin deren bundy müssen sein hammer
recht cool nicht sagt auch spuk
schutzsorte genannt hammer hammer noch
mal tschüss lecker schmecker prinz
michael vielleicht stellt ihr und eure
tortenplatte noch ein blech wurden und
ob ich hole mal kurz den ksc 40 den
massen
er schlägt alles weg